and need to be that guy One Last Time
For
[Music]
Us oh hey
Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size 4S huh how you so big look at the
big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down
up on6 sorry about the mess hold
on oh heo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy oh to God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip oh stop
and listen with
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in
the car can someone unlock the car
please call on
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way when I play a dop Melody anything L
than a a where
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I escaped at life and
now they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us
Ice Ice Baby look at you playing the
family man I'm not playing this is my
life I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait wait
go new
record